last year you Vsauce Far Cry series went
to the Stone Age next year it's gonna go
to modern-day America we recently had
some hands-on time with borrow five we
set some dogs on people we went fishing
it was a lot of fun it was a lot of fun
for everything five five five make sure
you subscribe including our latest
gameplay videos but for now these five
cool things from the game we think you
should know you can play farcry again
bear with me on this one
but those worried that Ubisoft would be
stepping away from their tried and true
formula we happy to hear far cry 5 still
feels very much like a Far Cry game
there have been some significant changes
though like the removal of the mini-map
and radio towers that you are required
to climb to unlock parts of the map on
top of that the game's initial marketing
material sparked speculation over
whether you be was positioning the game
as commentary on current events well
it's too early to say definitively
whether or not that's the case from our
time with the game Far Cry 5 seems to be
far more interested in delivering
familiar blockbuster action and chaotic
gameplay you'll equip yourself with
machineguns
sniper rifles and handguns to help you
meet out justice to the members of the
Eden's gate cult
the shooting is what you would expect
from Far Cry with different weapons
taking a little adjustment to use for
those that prefer the sneaky method you
can get up close and personal to perform
takedowns and enemies from behind or
snap them from vantage point so far from
their buddies lines of sight throwable
weapons make a return with silent
throwing knives and dynamite filling out
your already bursting weapon will
unleashing chaos by tossing a stick of
dynamite into a convoy as you emerge
from the trees rifle in hand it's still
just as fun and satisfying as ever you
can go fishing I used to go fishing a
lot when I was younger it is satisfying
to reel in a fish and it's a thrilling
challenge when you have a big one on the
line so of course when I learned to Far
Cry 5 had a fishing feature I had to try
it
a river runs through the section of the
map we played during our preview session
and depending on where you put your line
in you stand to catch something
different I started off by casting into
a shallow section of the river where I
was told trout would be after getting
used to the controls there's a button
for casting another button for reeling
and another for letting the line loose
so you don't snap it and landed my first
fish it's just like in real life you
have to control your line or else you'll
snap it and lose the fish but this only
gets more intense when you hook bigger
fish like the 51 pound sturgeon I caught
at one point dan and I totally forgot
our home county responsibilities and
competed to catch the biggest fish I
think I won this is not a fishing
simulator by any stretch but it's a fun
little diversion also you can cast your
line at an unsuspecting cow and
but don't expect them to like it play
with a pal Far Cry 5 let you play the
entire campaigning coop but in addition
to another human player you can team up
with buddy characters to help you out
grace acts as a sniper support character
Nick Ray is a pilot who can rain death
from above in his plane and boomer can
run off to grab weapons for you and rip
out the jugulars of your enemies Aizen
he's a dog by the way he's a good boy
the buddy system doesn't always click
though and it can be distracting during
a playthrough with Nick I didn't
immediately understand why he was there
or what he was meant to do but when you
specifically instruct Nick to go on a
bombing run to clear out an enemy camp
or to take out a truck that's when the
buddy system shines the same can be said
of the other buddies to using boomer to
take down an enemy while you sneak up on
his friend is satisfying but more often
than not he'll charge headlong into an
enemy camp alerting everyone to your
position grace can be posted up high to
provide sniping support or just as an
extra gun on the ground to keep you from
getting surrounded given you rarely have
your eye on her though she will
sometimes randomly dive very far away
from you and you'll have no idea what
happened fortunately though all your
buddies respawn eventually if they do go
down you can still be attacked by
everything as much as you might shudder
at the term emergent gameplay this is
what the Far Cry series does best and
from what we played it continues in Far
Cry 5 let me set the scene for you I was
fishing on a dock minding my own
business when a massive snarling wolf
the likes of which you might see in Game
of Thrones pounced on an unsuspecting
NPC fisherman standing next to me I
don't know if the man did something to
the wolf earlier that day or in a past
life or maybe the wolf just seize the
opportunity it doesn't really matter
because it was thrilling if not a
terrifying experience to witness it
wasn't a total loss however as I looted
the carcass of the man and the wolf
sorry not sorry
we also spotted what can only be
described as cows making cow babies and
you could still be minding your own
business wandering through a field
trying to make it to your next objective
when all of a sudden a bear rocks up to
rip your face off classic far cry fly
applying for the first time in Far Cry
you'll be able to take to the skies in
true 100% aeroplanes no more making do
with hang gliders and gyrocopters during
our preview session we were treated to a
mission where and we needed to destroy
some Eden's gate silos
from the pilot seat of a seaplane
luckily Hoch County's resident pilot
Nick I had outfitted the plane with a
minigun rocket launchers and bombs to
make this an easy task
during the mission we caught the
attention of the
a pilot and a dog fight ensued the plane
controls are immediately familiar the
left stick handles banking and pitch
while the shoulder buttons handle
weapons that said I hit the ground trees
and in one instance the enemy plane or
trying to reorient myself in
first-person and that's something that's
worth noting as with all Far Cry games
there is no view aside from first-person
keeping control of the plane while
trying to get a bead on flying enemies
take some serious hand-eye coordination
on par with rubbing your tummy while
patting your head luckily I wasted my
final year in high school perfecting
that skill so with practice I think I
could get the hang of flying in Far Cry
5 far cry 5 looks like it's gonna be
another familiar entry in the
long-running franchise I'll be it with
some significant changes here we have to
judge it for yourself when it comes out
on February 27 of next year but for the
meantime we're gonna be bringing you
everything you need to know for now let
us know what you think about how it's
shaping up in the comments below yeah
thanks for watching and now we can go
fishing huh I don't know what that was I
should have passing